- My name is Dan Powell.
I am the Director of Community
Platforms here in Central IT.
Presenting with me today, I
have two of my colleagues,
James Tucciarone and Mike van Emmenes.
And we're gonna talk to you a little bit
about the technologies that we offer
that you can use to engage
with your community.
How many of you were able to
see Nate Nickerson this morning
and talking about audience insights?
Very cool, so, a lot of the technologies
that I'm gonna be talking about,
the data of which will give you insight
into what your community
experience actually is,
and once you have that data
then you can turn around,
you can make better decisions
about the experience
that you want somebody to
have with your department
or your school or unit,
and you can start to create
that experience for them
based on what they need.
This is a bit of a
forward-looking picture.
You'll see the large
Salesforce piece in the middle.
That is mainly because
that is our chosen CRM
here on campus.
How many of you are Salesforce users now?
Do we have, we've got
a, okay, there we go.
So it's a really cool thing.
So this isn't, this represents
where we're trying to get to.
Once we start to knit together
all of these different technologies,
they feed into that Salesforce CRM,
and that CRM is what's
gonna be able to generate
that 360-degree view of
what somebody's experience
is here on campus.
It's not necessarily where we're at today.
Where we are at today
is we have Salesforce
as a CRM layer and it
consumes all of the data
from all of our upstream systems of record
and so everybody that we communicate with
in the Yale community gets
channeled into this CRM layer,
as well as anybody that is
interested in our content
around the globe gets
channeled into this CRM layer,
and then that layer feeds
Marketing Cloud or Yale Message,
which is our digital engagement platform,
which Mike van Emmenes is gonna talk
to you about in just a minute.
But there's also other
periphery technologies
that we offer here at Yale
that we're just starting now
to pull into and
integrate with Salesforce,
so Cvent, which is our conferencing.
Cvent was a technology that
organized today's conference,
the Digital Conference.
And Qualtrics is a survey tool,
also integrates in with Salesforce
as do the other technologies
that we're gonna talk to you about today.
So this is our actual agenda for today,
so I'm gonna start off
talking to you a little bit
about what we do on the customer
relationship management,
and I recognize that we are
an institution, a university.
We do not have customers.
Customer relationship management
is the industry's word for it,
but please feel free to substitute
that C for colleague or
constituent or community.
Then I'm gonna hand off
to Mike van Emmenes,
and he's gonna talk to you
about digital engagement
using Yale Message,
and then James Tucciarone
is going to take us
the rest of the way and talk
to us about calendaring events,
room reservation systems,
and survey here on campus.
So starting off with customer
relationship management.
This is really the heart
of the understanding
of what the community's
experience is that you serve.
You noticed it on the other pages
being that center focal point.
It tracks all the
interactions in conjunction
with your business process,
so it doesn't have to be around people,
it can certainly, it's
commonly around people,
but it can also be between assets
like equipment located in rooms
or people attending events.
It's very flexible and it's flexible
to meet your business process.
You might be thinking, it's
like, "Okay, but I track
"interactions today anyway", and so do I.
You've got Outlook.
We hear a lot about Excel.
Outlook, hey, I also group
my emails and conversations
so I can see who's talking
to when and what that
response part has been,
but when we talk about CRM,
we talk about taking those conversations
and then we put them in context
of what your business process is.
So if you have study for example,
and say you have a team
that's working on this study.
You're having this email
conversation with somebody.
Is that at the beginning of that process?
Is it in the middle of that process?
Is it at the end of that process?
So it can put those
conversations into context
of what your business process is
and what you're trying to accomplish.
The other thing with Outlook
is those are conversations
that are just between you and
somebody and might exclude
the rest of your team
that's working on it.
With Outlook, it integrates
in with Salesforce,
you can actually just assign
those email conversations
directly into your CRM
and so it tracks it there
and it gives it visibility
to the rest of the team
so we all are on the same page
walking through the business process.
It's very cool, very powerful,
but it's about adding that
context and that visibility
of where someone or something
is in their engagement path.
We do hear a lot about
that Excel spreadsheet
that different groups use
to track their interactions,
and this is just instead of it
being a very flat spreadsheet
that's hard to keep up with
this is a many-to-many type
of relationship that is
more robust and allows you
to actually track and have
visibility into your process.
It's all about process.
It's very flexible.
We chose Salesforce many, many years ago
both tactically and strategically.
If you think about Yale as an institution,
we support many different industries,
and many different schools and units
and we all have different
business processes,
so we needed something
that could be flexible
to adapt to each of those
different, unique processes,
but still being centered
around whatever that object is
that you're trying to understand better,
whether it be a person
or an asset or something,
and Salesforce gives us that,
which is why it's on campus.
I'm gonna give you a
few different examples
of instances we have on campus,
so this was a really fun one
with the Psychology Department
where they're using Salesforce in a way
to understand families and
their children and the studies
that they are participating
in now and historically,
as well as showing things
like tracking appointments
and no-shows and shows.
Another example on campus
is Conferences and Events.
We'll call this a CRM plus.
With them what we did is we configured it
so that they can track
the end-to-end process,
so from the time somebody
reaches out as a lead
to maybe hosting events on campus,
walking them all the
way through the process
to the time that they're
actually managing the logistics
of that event on campus,
and it also manages support
issues during the event
using a case management module.
And this one is also another
fun example of a CRM on campus.
It's for the Yale School of Public Health.
If you can imagine Match.com,
where you have a lot of
students that need mentoring
and alumni that might
want to act as mentors,
and so it takes alumni
opting in to be a mentor,
creating a profile for themselves,
and then allowing the students to come in
and research the different
alumni that have opted in
and then they can favorite
them and then they can start
building their own relationship
with their new mentor.
It's very fun, very cool,
very powerful stuff,
and once you have all
these types of things
within your process documented
and you're working through it
you start to have some
really rich analytics
around that and once
you have those analytics
it gives you even more
insight and more understanding
about what the possibilities
could be to help
or to meet your community's needs.
So you might be thinking
to yourself right now,
it's like, "Gosh, I didn't
know all this stuff,
"I would love to reach
out and understand more
and see what else we can do".
So what is it like to engage with us?
So for us, it's you just reach out
and we go through some vetting
to make sure that we're
understanding which technology
is the right choice for the problems
that you're trying to have,
and so let's say that it does happen
to be Salesforce on the CRM side.
What we would do is we'd
really get to engage with you
and really understand what
you're doing right now,
how you're doing it, and
how you wanna do it better,
and what your goals are,
and so once we start to
document out that entire process
we all get on the same page with that
and then we configure the tool for you
and it's a whole lot easier to adopt
and we've seen a lot of success
with doing that approach.
So that's my time,
and I'm gonna hand this over now to Mike
to talk to you about Yale Message.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
- Good afternoon everyone.
Who uses Yale Message here?
Majority of the room.
Who attended our session
just before lunch?
(Mike laughing)
So some of this might be
regurgitation for those people,
for other people, welcome.
Yale Message is a digital
communications platform
built on Salesforce.
In our current state we are
focusing on two key features.
We're focusing on the Email
Studio and Journey Builder.
Email Studio is precisely what that is,
it's sending email
communications to the community.
We gather data from our
data sources here at Yale,
so we're connected into the
People Hub, WorkDay, Hopper.
And those lists can be updated
as those systems of record are updated.
The other portion that we are
currently dealing with is Journey Builder.
Journey Builder's a really
cool feature in that you build
a journey for your list of people
who you're communicating with,
so you would have the list of people,
you would set up the
journey to go as expected,
send out a message,
and dependent on what each individual does
within that journey,
will send them down a
different type of path.
We've got a really cool
journey set up right now
with organizational development.
Travis is doing a phenomenal job
so we appreciate the
partnership, thank you.
(audience clapping)
(audience laughing)
But something that Travis
does is that there are
certain classes that are set
up and participants need to do
required reading before the class,
so the individuals on the list
will get the email through the journey.
If that person, if someone
does not open the email,
or if someone does not click
on the link within that email,
a different journey will be started up.
So if I'm in a class and my
class starts next Monday,
the journey started today, I got my email,
I just kept ignoring it,
Travis has set up that within
two days of me receiving it,
ping Michael again.
Ping him, ping him
until he opens the email
or until he clicks on the link
so that I read the required reading.
If I don't do either of those
and I show up for my class
and I'm ready to rock and roll,
the instructor knows that
I haven't done anything
and could possibly say, "Goodbye Michael,
"come back next time when you've
done the prescribed reading
"that we need for you
to do for the class."
In the future, we've got
two other great tools
that we're gonna focus on.
Mobile Studio, which is mobile messaging,
which can also be integrated
with the Journey Builder.
So Travis is super excited about that.
We know today's day and age
everyone likes their cellphone,
so if you don't read the
reading or open the email
we can then create a journey
that starts sending text
messages to your phone
if you've opted in for that.
And then Social Studio.
We all know the power of social media.
It's coming.
We're gonna get there.
Just some stats on where your
Yale Message is on the campus.
First off, it's a kudos to the team.
Today or June is our one-year anniversary
since we adopted Yale Message,
and in that time frame we've brought on
over 200 departments,
trained over 750 people,
we've got about 32 other
departments ready to come on board.
Another great success is up here.
We are with the Yale brand,
we've got the Yale font,
and we are freely accessible,
which we know is a huge requisite.
Another great statistic, year-to-date,
so in the first five months of this year,
we have successfully
sent over 30,000 emails
to 34 million recipients.
We've had an open success
rate of about 40%,
which is roughly about
8% better than it was
with our previous tool.
The other great feature with Yale Message
is obviously the analytics.
As Dan was referring to, pulling the data,
understanding the data.
With analytics that we receive,
we're able to identify who
the targeted audience truly is
and how they've interacted with us,
so if you send out an email
to, let's do my other number,
34 million people, which, pretty huge,
but only a million people
start interacting with you,
you've now got your targeted audience.
You know who they are, and
you target them specifically.
We are also able to get
open rates, click rates.
So you'll know who's opening your emails,
we'll know who's clicking on their emails.
There's a report within the email
of which clicks receive the
highest percentage of clicks.
So what your audience is actually
reading within that email.
Over here you can see a Delivery Rate.
We strive for that 99%
to 100% Delivery Rate.
You find out why people are
not receiving the emails.
If it's a hard bounce,
you can click on the
hyperlink and you can see
if that email address
was incorrectly written
or that email address just doesn't exist.
Soft bounce, if a
person's mailbox is full,
Yale Message will continue to try send
that email to the person for 72 hours,
hopefully getting through to them,
and then obviously a block bounce,
unfortunately there's not much we can do
with that in the real world.
It's someone's gone out and
specifically blocked you.
We did work with Salesforce
and we keep up with Salesforce
on white-listing our domain name.
Right now our domain is message.yale.edu.
It is at a higher white
list than yale.edu.
We're able to track it,
we're able to push it,
and we work with different
constituents to make sure
that emails get pushed through.
And then some really cool
features is when you start
to get into your email engagement,
you can see percentages of
who's gonna click on emails,
who's gonna open emails,
so you get a true sense
of how your community's engaging with you.
And that's it.
Up next, I'm gonna hand over to James.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
- All right.
So, I'll be taking over to talk to you all
about our calendaring and
event management tools.
Also our room reservation system
and our survey tool that we use on campus.
So to get started, we're gonna take a look
at calendaring and event management
which we support through
Bedework, Cvent and CrowdCompass.
Basically what we're trying
to do here is provide
a common set of tools that will help
in understanding your
target audience's engagement
as well as to facilitate
some policy adherence
while meeting some of
our critical requirements
in this field around campus.
So some of those
requirements are going to be
calendar publishing and cross listing,
submission and approval.
Also third-party integration.
We're looking to do event
and session management
as well as payment processing,
and then a mobile attendee
experience which is really neat,
and of course, as we've
mentioned a few times already,
reporting on top of all of this.
So I'm gonna break down the difference
between calendaring and
event management just a bit
because we've found over the years
that there is sometimes
a bit of a difference
in what people define as calendaring
and also events management.
So looking at calendaring,
here we have our Yale Calendar of Events.
This is also know as the Bedework system,
it's at calendar.yale.edu,
and basically this is
our unified event hub
for the university.
It's a great opportunity
for us to really be a part
of the vision of a unified
Yale here on campus,
and it's intended to
be the one place to go
for all of the events that
are taking place on campus,
and in that way, it improves
the experience for people
that are looking to
attend events on campus
as well as the general Yale community
and also some departments around campus
such as Public, excuse me,
Public Safety and Facilities.
So it also improves
visibility of your events
as calendar.yale.edu is calendar.yale.edu
and it's linked directly from yale.edu,
so it really pushes people to come
right to this calendar
system and really market
what is taking place here around campus.
So with the calendar here,
the requirements that we're trying to meet
are going to be those calendar
publishing and cross listing,
as well as the submission and approval,
and then of course we have
third-party integrations
which are really interesting, both custom,
such as our integration
with the Yale Arts Calendar,
and also out-of-the-box
such as our integration
with Yale sites.
And actually I'll pop back
there for just a moment.
So in here on the left-hand side,
we can see our landing
page for calendar.yale.edu,
and one thing to note about this is
that the Office of Public
Affairs and Communications
is our functional owner
for the calendar here,
however the individual
groups who are posting events
retain administrative
ownership of their events,
and some of the other groups
that are using the calendar
include the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences,
the MacMillan Center programs,
the School of Management,
we have West Campus,
we have approximately 100 different groups
that are actually using
the calendar currently.
And so now moving into our
event management tools,
which we support with
Cvent here on campus,
and Cvent is an event
management system that automates
and simplifies the entire
event planning process,
and it offers tools that
run the entire gamut
from vendor, excuse me, venue sourcing,
all the way to real-time dashboards,
and reporting at the end of your event.
So we can see here it provides us
with a number of different opportunities.
In our lens here,
some of the requirements we can see
that we're meeting are
gonna be event registration
and payment processing.
Of course we also have marketing,
which is great and fits right in
with some of our other tools,
and then some of our add-ons
which are really neat
is we have an on-site solution
which Cvent calls their
white glove service,
where they send people down
here to actually man your event
and they handle the registration process
where they will print ID
cards, handle check-in,
get everybody set up, et cetera,
and something else that they offer
which is really cool is live polling.
So during a presentation such as this,
you can actually get
feedback from your audience
and have an interactive
discussion about something
that you're actually talking about.
So as Dan mentioned earlier,
everybody here today had
an experience with Cvent
when they registered for the
Digital Conference, right?
And then a number of other groups
around campus are using it as well,
so the Office of Development
and the Yale Alumni Association
are two large users, as
well as the Law School,
School of Management.
We also have Athletics
which is really interesting.
And then just a couple of the features
that are in here with Cvent,
as we saw already with this lens here.
So we have an online
event registration program
which provides also a
branded website experience,
and then of course provides us
that secure payment processing.
The tool also allows us
to manage our attendees
as well as our speakers and our
exhibitors and our sessions,
and then of course you know it provides us
with that robust reporting mechanism
that is really required
across all of our tools.
So that steps us into our
mobile attendee engagement
or experience application,
and this is CrowdCompass,
which is a subsidiary of Cvent,
and basically it's a mobile
application that your users
can use while they're
actually attending an event,
and basically, what Cvent, excuse me,
what CrowdCompass states is
that there's two primary reasons
that people attend a
conference or an event,
and that's so that they can
engage with your content,
and so that they can
engage with other people,
and CrowdCompass is
really, really powerful
for doing that as it allows
us to engage with our peers
through social networking and
it allows us to get engaged
with our content and our
speakers through attendee
and speaker tools that are available.
The other thing that it
provides is an ability
for us to have another opportunity
to engage our attendees
with our brand in general.
So we can see some of the,
in our second bullet here,
some of the items that are really useful
within the system is going
to be the session scheduling,
we have speaker profiling,
interactive maps,
and push notifications.
A couple of really interesting things
that have been coming about
lately is we've been seeing
a lot of integration with
augmented reality and wayfinding.
So for instance, at a Facebook
conference a few years back,
they actually had one of
these nice little badges here
where you flipped it over,
looked at it with your phone
and you had a 3D floor plan
representation of the campus
that the Facebook conference
was taking place at.
Another example we've
seen is using your phone
to look where you're going
and having a dotted line
that's wayfinding you to
wherever your location is.
So for somebody that's really not familiar
with the campus or the location,
it's a great way, I mean,
hopefully we still watch
and check both ways
before we turn the street,
or cross the street rather,
but one really, really interesting thing
that I find is that we see the statistic
that on average attendees for a conference
check their phone 200 times a day.
So if we consider that statistic,
we can see how very easily CrowdCompass
can become such a powerful tool.
And of course with CrowdCompass,
some of the groups that are
using this is Commencement,
one of our biggest events that
are taking place on campus.
We also do the Yale-Harvard weekend.
We have the School of
Management Welcome Weekend,
we have some orientations,
so we have a number of
sort of high profile events
that are being used
through this application,
and again, the great thing about this is
it really gets right to
the heart of your attendees
and it gives them an experience
that's beyond just registration
and understanding what's taking place.
So moving on now, I'm
gonna talk about our room
and booking management system.
So this is the room reservation system.
Some of your might also know this as EMS,
which is Event Management System,
as opposed to Expense or
Emergency Management System.
There's no confusion
with that at all, right?
So, basically, EMS is our space
and booking management system.
It also allows for some resource booking.
One of the great things
about this is it allows
for granular access and when
appropriate we can also do
an automated user load.
There's also an, excuse me,
an integration with Exchange
as well as with Banner,
and it's really powerful in its ability
to provide us with some functionality
around scheduling
scenarios and optimization,
and we also have of course API access
and let's see here, and then, of course,
as with all of our other tools,
have a robust reporting mechanism as well.
So we can see that there's a number
of different things that EMS can do,
and I like to call it a space
and object management system
because it's not really
just about rooms anymore.
In fact, the School of
Drama is using this system
to manage some of their
vehicles that they allow
for check-in and check-out.
And in addition to the School of Drama,
we also have the Law School,
which is actually the
group that implemented EMS
on campus about 10 years ago,
and then the School of Public
Health sort of adopted it
as well before it became
centrally managed,
and now we have about two
dozen different groups,
including School of Management,
who in all fairness is managing
their own instance of EMS,
however they are using EMS,
and then we also are recently rolling out
the Medical Library,
YCBA, the Art Gallery,
and a number of various
departments around campus.
So one of the most exciting things for me
that are coming about right
now is digital room signage.
So digital room signage
is a tablet-sized device
that is installed outside of a space,
and basically it provides an application
that shows you whether or
not the room is available
and what's taking place in that room
over the course of the day.
Also, if you choose to do so,
you can have people
interact with this device
as they're walking up to a space.
So if the space is available,
somebody can walk right
up and reserve the space,
or if you have a lot
of problems with people
not actually showing up
for their reservations
you can actually require them to check in
so that that way if they
don't check in the space
is released and somebody
else can then use that space
and you're not just sitting
there with a wasted room.
So this is an example of the application,
and right now we have this
also implemented in a number
of places around campus.
The School of Management is
one really great example,
and if you ever have an opportunity
to go over to their site,
you can see this on most
if not all of their rooms
within the building.
Divinity has also implemented
a number of these devices
along with the Institute of Sacred Music.
Nursing is going to be
putting in about 80 or so
as a part of their renovation
process, and the Center,
excuse me, the Cushing/Whitney
Medical Library
has also implemented a
number of these as part
of their renovation which
is actually, I believe,
opening on Thursday, so
if anybody's interested
in seeing them there as well.
And here I just have an image.
We can see a couple of, and I'm sorry,
I know this is probably not
the most clearest image,
but we can see that we have a couple
of the devices here at SOM.
We have one right over here and
we have one right over here,
and with these particular
pieces of hardware,
you can actually see
that there's an LED strip
on either side of the device,
so even if you don't walk
right up to the device,
from a distance you can actually see
whether or not a room is available
and decide if you wanna go
ahead and go to that room
and maybe have a meeting.
And so that's gonna then bring us
into survey management and design.
So for that, we use Qualtrics
to support this need,
and Qualtrics can do
so many things, right?
And we can see just some
of those things right here.
So we have student engagement,
we have online course
evaluations, we have dashboards,
we have patient care, we
have employee experience,
and one of my favorite
things since this is
sort of my area here is that
you can actually even use it
for really simple registration
and RSVP, that's pretty cool.
And so it's available to
all Yale faculty, staff,
and students for the
business of the university,
and in addition it is
approved for PHI data,
and Qualtrics states that it is helpful
in increasing the speed and
the quality of our research
and overall it improves our
engagement, our experience,
and our user satisfaction.
And I think that's pretty much it for me,
so I think I'll go ahead and
turn this back over to Dan
for him to wrap us up,
(Dan laughing)
and I thank you very much.
- Yeah, thanks.
(audience clapping)
Awesome.
I think I just get the
final thank you slides.
(audience member laughing)
So just wrapping this back to
our forward-looking statement.
So all the technologies that you saw,
we are trying to actively
knit those together
into a Salesforce CRM so that we can start
understanding the audience insights
that we were talking about earlier,
which is really, really awesome
because then we can start to understand,
it's like that one person
that comes into our community
and how many different places
that they actually touch
and how many departments and
understand what their interests
actually are so that we
can better serve them.
And with that, that's it.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Could you come up?
(gentle melodic tones)